Researchers have recorded the genome in 4D
--tracking the location of  DNA strands in 3 dimensions
over time.
Our chromosomes don’t always look like neat little Xs.
A lot of the time our genetic material
more closely resembles a pile of spaghetti.
Even in the spaghetti state, genes move further and closer with purpose
--forming loops of DNA.
Many loops are bound by cohesin molecules.
The cohesin acts as an “extruder”
pulling two areas of DNA together
and extruding out the loop
from the material in between.
By removing and then adding this protein
researchers made specific DNA loops
disappear and then reappear.
But cohesin really only affects looping that
brings genes on the same chromosome into contact.
A second, still undefined mechanism seems
to bring genes from different chromosomes together.
The shifting landscape of loops helps cells quickly
change which genes are active.
Understanding this dance could help researchers
better understand a nd treat genetic disease.